[Music]
hey guys
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
in this video we're going to be
discussing jk rowling everyone's
favorite aspect of harry potter
the cursed child kidding and just how
related the play
and author actually are the cursed child
comes under continuous scrutiny from the
harry potter fans worldwide
mainly for its disregard for traditional
harry potter canon
though rowling has affirmed that the
play should be accepted as part of canon
most fans aren't having any of this this
is for a couple of reasons
first of all the storyline truly upsets
our perceptions of the traditional harry
potter universe
the notion that voldemort could have a
child when he was born entirely devoid
of certain emotions
it's just one example of the things that
the cursed child did that didn't set
well with fans
the next big issue for most fans is that
rolling didn't write the play
all on her own and because other people
had influence on how the play and
story would turn out it seems to be the
general consensus among fans
that it can't truly be canon on the
front cover it very clearly reads
based on an original new story by jk
rowling
john tiffany and jack thorne the cursed
child is marketed as the eighth story
the story of the children of the
characters that we grew up with
the events of the cursed child occur 19
years after
the events of the deathly hallows and
follows harry potter
who is now head of the department of
magical law enforcement at the ministry
of magic
and his younger son albus potter who's
just about to embark on his own journey
at hogwarts but rather than being made
into a film adaptation
the cursed child is a two-part play and
was written
to be a play so given the obvious
differences between this work
and jk rowling's previous work and the
fact that she co-wrote it
just how involved was rowling with the
plot and character development
was this a product of jack thorne and
john tiffany or jk rowling
jk rowling initially never wanted to
make a stage adaptation of her work
it wasn't for her but producers sonja
friedman and colin calendar
were eventually able to successfully
pitch the idea to rowling
over the years i've received countless
approaches about turning harry potter
into a theatrical production
but sonja and colin's vision was the
only one that really made sense to me
and which had the sensitivity intensity
and intimacy
i thought appropriate for bringing harry
story to the stage
after a year in gestation it is exciting
to see this project moving on to the
next phase
i'd like to thank warner brothers for
their continuing support in this project
and what this tells me is that the whole
idea and a large portion of the story
were put in place before rowling was
even involved from what rowling has
revealed in interviews
it seems like the original idea was
created by jack thorne john tiffany
sonja friedman and colin calendar rather
than the author that produced the works
of our childhood
sonja friedman takes full ownership of
the idea in an interview
why a play was it jk rowling's idea it
was absolutely collins and my idea
we knew that many other producers had
approached her and she had rejected
their pitches
but that's because they were all ideas
about musicals or arena spectacles
we went to her with the simple idea of a
straight play
we were clear we didn't want to adapt a
novel and we suggested exploring how
harry
and orphan would cope as an adult and a
parent we went up to edinburgh four
years ago
and sat in a boardroom and talked about
fathers and parenting for a while
we said we felt she'd created a fully
dimensional world and there were things
about the characters she hadn't revealed
we didn't hear anything for a bit then
got the call to say
let's go to the next stage when rowling
was asked why she changed her mind
she said the following meeting sonja
friedman jack thorne and john tiffany
changed my mind i knew there was at the
material there i gave it all to them and
they've turned out the play
from there the seeds were planted and
planning began to produce the play
that is the cursed child when tiffany
and dawn were asked about sharing story
credit with rowling
they said the following joe rolling was
incredibly generous
when we met to talk about the play she
asked what do you think the harry potter
stories are about
i said learning to deal with death and
grief there was something in her eye
i thought we didn't say it's about
transformation or magic
or flying on brooms and we're on the
right track we all met in edinburgh and
as the day developed
we knew we would take the epilogue of
harry potter and the deathly hallows as
a starting point
jk rowling was very clear from the
beginning that she was not a playwright
and wouldn't be involved with actually
writing the play the play was to be
written by jack thorne and john tiffany
and that was always the plan however
this doesn't mean that she wasn't
involved at all
and i think that fans have perhaps
disassociated rolling from the play
a little bit more than they should have
rowling was still very much involved
with plot
and character development she didn't
entirely hand off the story
and give him total creative freedom she
was still a voice that had a significant
influence on the play
when thorne and tiffany were originally
given the go-ahead they met rowling in
her writing room
and strung together the narrative for
the story together right then
and there i told john and jack what i
thought had happened to harry
ron and hermione in later years
explained how focused i was on harry's
son albus
who'd been given the burden of not one
but three legendary names
and together we created the story that
jack wrote at this point thorne and
tiffany got to writing
from this point onward they would
continually touch base with rowling
to ensure that the story meshed well
with the universe that she had created
additionally rowling had considerable
veso power over the story
and if something didn't sit well with
her then it was not going to end up in
the final product
this is something that i feel is glossed
over by many fans
rowling still had a massive amount of
influence in the story
thorne was a longtime superfan of harry
potter and it has been expressed that he
had
anxiety about treading on such hallowed
ground fair enough
i had a big advantage my first reader
was john and my second was joe
if you've got the person out of whose
head these characters came then you go
okay i can make some choices if they're
the wrong ones she'll say
and she did i'm pretty sure i could have
been fired at any time
whenever i mention the cursed child in
videos it seems to get a lot of hate
and this is where i don't feel quite as
strongly as some other people
do i view the cursed child on the same
level as the traditional harry potter
story
not even close but do i appreciate that
the cursed child
is a genuine attempt to continue the
story made by fans working alongside
rolling herself
certainly the story wasn't just handed
off to them with no questions asked
for years and years rowling consistently
denied proposals to create stage
adaptations of her novels
for 10 years i said no to proposals to
adapt harry for the stage
usually as a musical and using the
existing books
so when i met producers sonia friedman
and colin calendar
i wasn't sure what i was going to hear i
only knew that they wanted to do
something new
which was intriguing because i had no
desire to go endlessly back over old
ground
so while the cursed child is constantly
scrutinized for veering away from the
traditional harry potter canon
we do need to remember that rowling did
have a role in
its creation and if something truly
veered far enough away from the universe
that we know and love she could have at
any time vetoed it
there are some hard pills to swallow in
the cursed child
and things that i agree just don't seem
to work with everything else that we've
been introduced to
but as a standalone production it should
be appreciated
i'm just not convinced that it's cut
from the same cloth as everything else
however you feel about it i get it it's
quite a controversial topic
and that's it for this video what do you
guys think of the cursed child
can you appreciate it for what it is on
its own or does it serve as too much of
an affront
on harry potter let me know down in the
comment section
below until next time your wizard harry
you